the Joe Rogan experience it's doing
weird [ __ ] that's the only thing and
gentlemen it's you know and I don't you
know weird [ __ ] in the sense of like
y'all [ __ ] that excites you since it's
like you know you know don't know I've
never tried to make the same thing twice
you know because it's like I want to be
excited I want you scared to fail yeah
yeah I don't know I want to be like you
know oh that didn't work next time yeah
well you you've always switched [ __ ] up
that's one of the more interesting
things about you it's like when when you
were doing what it's like and when you
switched up to like whitey Ford sings
the blues everybody was like whoa like
what is this is this is Chris is the
jump around God is the House of Pain guy
but it it it was a it felt so easy to
digest for most people because before I
knew you and I was like it's so easy
because it's so authentic like it's very
obvious that this was thank you the kind
of music that you were writing was like
music that like came from your feelings
and your soul it was like wow this is
real [ __ ] I was 20 20 years ago what
it's like was a classic that was a
classic that was one of those songs was
like that's a heartfelt song that's a
soul filled song you know that's like a
universal song yeah I went to New York I
had left House of Pain and went to New
York with a buddy of mine and was just
kind of sleeping on his couch and he had
a guitar there I start strumming it one
night and singing these little words and
he came bursting out of his room in the
back like what the [ __ ] is that
and kinda was like we're recording that
tomorrow we were making a rap record I
was like they're like just kind of
further you know the rap career and
nobody really knew I played guitar and
stuff like that a little bit so but it
was his hit his encouragement it
definitely came back he liked when he
was like I think he was with it broad
back there and he just heard the song
and jumped what the [ __ ] is that you
know I mean and and so the next day they
basically forced me to record it so I
had to finish right I had wrote it like
that night I think I had the first part
the whole liquor store or guy at the
liquor store thing
but I didn't really have anything else
but he heard that part was like yo we
need to finish that when you get those
ideas when they come to you what does
that feel like does it feel like like a
gift comes out of the University's mouth
the really good ones yeah you know I
mean I I mean what blows my mind and I'm
gonna flip it on you real quick is is
the dick the comic art arc of you get to
work this thing out for a whole long
time and if you're really successful on
your level type thing then you shoot a
special and that joke kind of goes away
you can't really tell that anymore
if that blows my mind because like my
whole thing is like work this thing out
and build this thing that I can go out
and play every night for the rest of my
life